I'm gonna share with you my opinions in
a piece we're calling Oscar movie
reviews our first nominee is the film
boyhood now for this movie director
Richard Linklater famously filmed a
six-year-old boy growing older
year-by-year it took 12 years to make
the film but I thought sometimes it took
Linkletter I don't know it just he made
strange choices he could have slowed
down the pace a little bit sometimes I
thought the growth happened a little too
quickly take a look dad there's no like
real magic in the world right Oh what if
I told you a story about how underneath
the ocean there was this giant sea
mammal that used sonar sang songs it was
so big that its heart was the size of a
car and you could call
[Music]
[Applause]
why would the gravestone be in the bed
I'm sorry that's just stupid
you should be mad about that
that makes no logical sense he got so
old he died and we put his gravestone in
the bed another nominee is Leviathan a
Russian movie that's up for Best Foreign
Language Film the acting's terrific
especially the actor who plays the mayor
but I was disappointed in the movies
subject matter it just didn't seem
enough
[Laughter]
now position compare another philosophy
concerning the productivity growth but
if we do mr. baracs Adam Savage
[Music]
our next nominated movie is whiplash
whiplash is about a young jazz drummer
prodigy and the sadistic music teacher
who attempts to break him now it's a
great film but after a while I wondered
why is the teacher being so hard on this
one drummer when there are clearly much
bigger problems in his jazz band see if
you agree not quite my tempo it's all
good no worries here we go rushing
you're talking to him right
[Music]
[Music]
come on
[Music]
I'm okay I'm okay
all right guys we'll take it from the
top nice reflexes
[Applause]
and finally there is Selma now I
absolutely love the movie but many
critics complained that the film was
full of historical inaccuracies and I
have to admit I did notice it during
this one scene see if you can find it -
[Music]
we got 128 miles to come to our centers
Jim Hoge this here's the place we need
to beat this right here is the next
great battle
[Applause]
[Music]
you